[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin and this week the focus is on the
eagerly awaited second meeting between
US president Donald Trump and North
Korean leader Kim jong-un it had been
hoped that the summit in the Vietnamese
capital Hanoi would use the promise of
economic development to build on the
historic first meeting in Singapore but
the summit finished earlier than planned
after the two leaders failed to bridge
their differences and no joint statement
was signed it seems that for the time
being the hope of trading concessions on
economic sanctions for concrete
denuclearization measures will not be
realized so our question on quadriga
this week is No Deal in Hanoi what next
for Kim and Trump and to discuss that
question I'm joined here in the studio
by dr. Jin hyung hyung joong from the
Institute of Korean Studies at Berlin's
free University he says no more
tug-of-war instead it's time for the
u.s. to show that it's also willing to
take irreversible steps towards peace
for our future generation also with this
theory Kirschbaum author and journalist
who writes for the Los Angeles Times and
Eric believes that talking is better
than testing Trump deserves credit for
convincing North Korea to at least
temporarily stop testing nuclear weapons
and firing missiles and a warm welcome
to two cherry chan Hong Kong born
journalists currently with Deutsche
Welle social media and Asia desks she
argues that China is supportive of more
u.s. North Korea interaction as long
that is as they don't get too cozy with
each other it doesn't look as though
that's going to happen for the time
being thank you all three for being here
on quadriga today I'd like to begin with
you Jin Hyun Jung let me ask you what
your response is to the tribute dramatic
developments in Hanoi
well obviously the the lot that last
night I was full of expectation at all
however when I woke up in the morning
you know and we immediately look at the
news
founded myself often frustrated however
obviously yeah peace seems to need more
patience in time although we've been
waiting for 70 years so far and on the
Korean Peninsula so a long time frame
you said you you had expectations and
hope can you describe those expectations
well basically I you know the North
Korea especially last year shows that
there and especially the leader Kim
jong-un shows his form will to some
process for further degradation so last
year they shut down and also literally
exploded one of the nuclear test site
and also there is no test right the
dimension so and I expect that the
United States government especially
Trump government who do some progressive
step forward especially the arms you
know the for the demands of North
Koreans yeah
request for the next steps however it
didn't happen so that's why I was
frustrated in the morning Jerry you are
not Inc no actually I think that's from
the China side China's point of view
they didn't really expect any agreement
or peace do to be rich in this submit
like before the summit happen they
actually already said that they know
that at the nuclearization process is a
really slow process and it cannot be
reached with just one step and so they
didn't really have a lot of expectation
but they I think China is rather
disappointed by not having sanctions or
partially partial sanctions lived on
North Korea because I think China's
concerned that the biggest concern of
China is economic development of North
Korea when you talk about China are you
talking about the Chinese authorities
are about the Chinese people because
you're very much coming from a social
media perspective yeah what I was
talking about is the voice of the
Chinese media like the chinese state
media but about the chinese public
actually they also don't think that it
would be such a remarkable summit
they were after after this
talks break down people on social media
they were saying that like we know that
this is a political show and it's just a
comedy and we're laughing about it so
political show a comedy Eric or a major
setback for the US president no three I
don't think it just sit back at all I
mean I think the expectations were
probably a bit too high
driven by Trump himself yeah but he was
trying to scale down by saying he's in
no rush but at least they're talking I
mean let's roll back the clock to a year
and a half ago fire and fury talking
about Rocket Man Rocket missile tests
we're stunt towards towards Guam it was
a really tense moment and my buttons
bigger than your button I mean this is
only a year and a half ago and now
they're sitting down and talking and
okay they didn't come up with a great
deal today or whatever but at least
they're gonna keep talking so I think to
call it a failure is wrong I think a lot
of people in the United States and in
security are probably relieved that
Trump didn't get away to did not give
away too much
that was definitely a fear of Hawaii
anything this time around well there
might be some diplomatic relations
opened up and they're agreeing to
continue to talking but there was a real
fear after the Singapore summit in June
that Trump would give away too much that
he would reduce sanctions before North
Korea was really willing to give up
nuclear weapons and that's the key to
the whole thing
and there's there's relief in the United
States right now among people who will
follow this closely that he did not go
too far and the Americans a bit
disappointed that compared to the first
summit dates essentially no change and
no progress at all because like the fire
theory is like as you said one and a
half year ago but then after the
Singapore submit I think the Americans
or people in the world they are
expecting more coming out from there was
expectations and there was a euphoria
about that and it was a remarkable
situation when Trump was suddenly
calling him as friend and things like
that I mean maybe it's not a good idea
to be called a friend by Trump we know
what happened to Michael Cohen and other
people have been his friend but at least
they were talking and at least North
Korea was not testing Rockets anymore
wasn't testing missiles wasn't wasn't
what had put a freeze to that and that
was a really positive thing I think
most Americans even Americans who don't
really like Trump recognize this was a
pretty important thing and he he
succeeded in areas where presidents from
Clinton to Obama to Bush were not able
to succeed
he got North Korea talking and seriously
I happened to have the pleasure of
trying to cover a summit in early 90s
right here in Berlin we stood outside
the North Korean embassy for days on and
nobody would say anything to us these
were sort of low level talks North Korea
was not talking at all then and now at
least they're talking they're looking
for ways forward surge in the world his
rights led by Donald Trump to invest
trust in the North Korean leader yeah I
think it's definitely I definitely agree
with our Eric's comments on the progress
there is a I think it's drastic to
progress and and I you know I understand
that you know here Europe and other
effects really don't even a stage well
the people distrusted Trump right and
also I I briefly took a look at the news
media says that also Jim German I was
watching or maybe at these media Barra
Michael Quinn's testimony and then Jim
John was quite also disappointed and
with you know all the Mike Mike Quinn's
expect much zips that kim jongwan also
started a little bit you know doubt
doubt about the sincerity of trump trump
site so however actually as the south
korean actually we definitely expect you
know the especially the Trump
administration to more reliable and
trustful steps at then we believe
actually we can he can do that and he
must do that so now I think the whole
power game seems to cousin to the drop
site however also North Korean
government especially a chairman Kim
would definitely do his best to make
more progress in the near future so you
think he was expecting too much do you
think he really thought Trump was gonna
say okay we're gonna lift the sanctions
I mean no no no actually you know I
don't know I
I don't people understand he is
intention however and I in Korea we
expected at least you know there is some
partial reduction parcel it definitely
the easement of the Chrome extensions
right this is the first step at least
you know North Korea force the showed
that their willingness to the process of
denuclearization last year and also this
is actually released reversible a step
and they already made and they've k1 it
focused an economic development a much
more than the military power development
so so this is I thinks we we understand
this is North Koreans form a decision so
it's now actually a trump government and
I think the United Stated in general
most to show they're they're also
interesting building up these peace
process and Korean Peninsula okay second
the summit in Hanoi the one thing I
think we can agree on brought together
two very unusual leaders in Donald Trump
and Kim Jong hoon of the two I think
less is perhaps known about the North
Korean supreme leader before I ask our
guests what they can tell us about Kim
here are some brief impressions Kim
jong-un was given a spectacular send-off
as he left Pyongyang for the summit he
certainly enjoys these kinds of events
whether it's military parades or nuclear
weapons tests
[Music]
since Kim came to power in 2011 he has
been a thorn in the side of the United
States but North Korea's economy is in a
shambles due in large part to
international sanctions
Kim has vowed to get the economy moving
again in April 2018 Kim met South
Korea's president moon jae-in for the
first inter-korean summit in 11 years in
June Kim traveled to Singapore for a
summit meeting with US President Donald
Trump but made only vague promises about
denuclearization what can we expect from
Kim at the Hanoi summit what can we
expect now in the immediate aftermath of
the Hanoi summit and I suppose cherry
just tell us get tell us sir
the one thing we need to know what I
need to know to understand Kim better i
think kim jeong-hoon is seen at least in
the region he is the second youngest
state leader in the world and people in
the region see him as very progressive
compared at least to his father and his
grandfather and they would expect more
from kim jeong-hoon because he also
studied abroad when he was young and he
had some international experience Kim a
progressive leader is not the way he is
seen in South Korea as well surely not I
I think it's definitely South Korea
actually oh yeah since they are they
also the inter-korean summit last year
South Korean people came to think that
you know Kim Jong is definitely much
more open than liberal and at the same
time she already stabilized this on
power in the country so yeah and then
people changed change their perspective
and in Kim Jong on the lock actually
it's more in positive than negative
and it's interesting we talked a lot
about the chemistry between Donald Trump
and and Kim what about between Kim and
president moon yeah yeah obviously since
the day already established really close
mutual relationship you know South
Koreans don't need to improve they will
she normalized the relationship with
North Korea otherwise you know just
attempt to Mystic problems in South
Korea economic problems and also also
people's minds then you know there's the
internal internal conflicts within South
Korea so you know I was asked where
people especially the really appreciated
and respect the president moon really
tried to really try to normalize the
relationship North Korea but without the
support from the United State and on
also international society particularly
Europe and in Germany you know I think
the this internal normalization process
is not possible where is Kim likely to
go next Eric on the train back to North
Korea I mean the fact that he had to
take a train is interesting I'm
detective trainee well plane he doesn't
have a plane that's a problem he flew to
Singapore on a China plane because the
his government plane is 60 years old and
missing some spare parts that says a lot
about the situation North Korea it's
economically as the show mentioned the
program mentioned in shambles Kim is the
one under pressure he needs to bring
something home he's got to give up
especially within the Korean economy is
coming from from way down deeper from
the from the urban power elite everybody
I mean a lot of the people a lot of the
elites in the government have been
abroad right the 30 to 40 year olds
studied abroad have been abroad have
been to Singapore wherever they see that
there's a world out there they can see
what can happen the whole the the whole
North Korean media that was following
this someone in Vietnam they would not
have missed that Vietnam is a
flourishing country right now
Vietnam was on was destroyed after the
Vietnam War Vietnam was poor the North
Korea the North Korea was helping
Vietnam in the 70s look how the tide has
turned
Vietnam when the United States had a
very rough relationship but there are
great friends now Trump was trying to
send these tacit messages look North
Korea look what could happen he was
saying that every other every other
minute as well this is the potential for
North Korea
what happened Vietnam look at that in
and I like you mention about it is train
trip it's actually it's also means a lot
to the actual South Korean people as
well you know South Korea unlike former
divided Germany the inter-korean border
is on it's not penetrable at all there
is no interaction
and also such credits the national
security law really really forbidden
people prohibit people from South Korea
to travel to North Korea without any
permission from the South Korean
government but now and then so it's
obscure it's like an island if you
wanted to go abroad you have to take
airplane right
so now they found that if you if if we'd
normalized relations North Korea but we
have already trained railway so it's
connected between between North Korea
and South Korea and then once the open
border is open we can travel people can
imagine you can travel to North Korea to
China Middle East Asia Vietnam and also
the up to here in the building so this
is completely different imagination
about the wall right
this is recall I cover more continental
mindset previously the island mindset so
it's so you know this is a very symbolic
action you just ride this train trip
also brings to this sort of Korean
people's mindset and at the same time
you know Vietnam or definitely in
history Kali historically it's a
similarity between us in South Korea
right so especially the war there was
war between Vietnam and United States in
North Korea and United States and
Vietnam claim that they won the war
against United States and North Korea
also claim that they want this Korean
War has United States so and at the same
time Vietnam status to maintain some
sort of its social it's the system right
so this is darker maybe Chinese model
parle Chinese table but also now North
Korea is very interested in Viet Nam's
model for their economic growth I just
want to go back to your point about the
train ride actually it is a very big
talking point in on Chinese social media
and first of all the Chinese people
they're really proud that like Kim is
taking this train ride across the whole
China not a whole China but like a
really long way in China and China is
responsible for providing security and
like cleaning like clearing or the train
tracks and roads for for him to pass
through and but then they also think
that it's disturbance for them because
like when they pass through the whole
China that pass through China like
people cannot go to work on time they
cannot take the training on time and I
saw some videos and pictures of people
talking about this training and then
saying that like complaining about it
basically and yeah okay as we have
already seen the first meeting between
the two leaders Trump and Kim took place
eight months ago in Singapore this time
the Vietnam Vietnamese capital Hanoi
provide leaders we've been hearing the
backdrop for the summit and that was
widely viewed as an important because
there are many who believed that Viet
Nam's booming economy could provide a
model a template for similar economic
growth in North Korea we'll talk about
that in just a second
after these images luxury cars
manufactured in Vietnam a sign of a
booming economy gross domestic product
is growing at an annual rate of about 6%
more and more people can now afford to
buy a car skyscrapers seem to be going
up everywhere Hanoi has become a city
that's open for business 24 hours a day
consumer spending is high Viet Nam's
economy is a mix of communism and
capitalism the Communist Party still
rules the country with an iron hand but
a recent poll indicated that most people
approve of the country's free-market
system
Vietnam is rapidly becoming a Southeast
Asian economic powerhouse could North
Korea learn from Viet Nam's experience
ian is he said that the the North Korean
authorities have made it their business
to study the the Vietnamese model that
we just been hearing about the domore
model as it's called what will they have
learnt and what will they with today as
do they view it as a viable model for
North Korea's future well it to be
honest actually I was till South Korea
experts also studied studying about the
possibility and also with potential of
this be enemies model whether it is fit
into North Korea or not it's a starting
point but you know the historical
similarities and also the probability I
think you noticed vietnam vietnamese
government was very successful
they attract more foreign investments
now japan and south korea is the number
one and to investing a lot of factories
and also development development the
projects in vietnam so in a sense like
now the previously divided in an under
underwent a severe city PCB wall place
which is vietnam you know says i think
also the people and in vietnam is
Vietnamese people so pretty much I
things were discipline in a sense
negative in terms of their personality
at the same time their sincerity
remember in working and also dealing
with the human relationship so at least
there are some some sort of the kind of
also this kind of basic similarities
also being quite animated I'd like to
come from a German perspective cherry
the the the sense that the economic
model from Vietnam for Donald Trump was
an incentive that he was offering to the
to the to North Korea and saying this is
what you could get and he actually said
that he said that the North Korean
leader could remain in power and could
be the man who enforces this as it were
how troubled should we be as I say
coming from a German perspective where
two people tend to sort of moralize
quite a lot yeah how should we be that
that this is a despot a dictator that
this offer is being made to I don't
think this is a big concern for Trump
that he is a dictator
Kimmy's a dictator and I think he wants
to really provide this incentive for
North Korea to open his economy first
and then we can like he can see after
that how the country develops and I
think it's actually quite attractive for
North Korea to learn from Vietnam
because she and I managed to open up his
economy and at the same time hold on to
his political power is basically still
one-party one-party state and I think
North Korea would really want to very
attractive option for North Korea yeah
for North Korea but not from other parts
of the world we're still talking here
about are we talking about North Korea
in South Korea are we talking possibly
in the future about a united Korea it's
hard to imagine the united Korea I think
Korea is South Korea studied the German
unification as a model and wow it's
expensive and I think they're a bit
freaked out about that I I don't know I
don't I don't hear any talk of Korean
unification this is sort of a pipe dream
from people who don't live in the region
or but it's a very expensive thing and
German unification is still a work in
progress
yeah obviously uh you know determine
Germany and Korean Peninsula shared
similar tastes good movement however
determinate did not undergo a severe
internal civil war between East and West
Berlin East and West Germany while North
and South Korea underwent a stable world
and then based on this experience some
of emotional emotional sentiment
emotional and negative emotional
reactions to news Kirino so-called
anti-north Korean sentiment is still
strong in South Korea however and then
the the economic perspective on this
unification I think is still I think it
must be criticized as well it was
obviously in young people in South Korea
concern about these money you know how
much money they have to pay for the
whole process of unification however we
believe there is more advantageous
advantages to the normal in normalizing
the relationship then maintaining this
division you know we have to
Reverso Texas for the military weapons
and also also young people most
especially South man was to go to
military service right and this is also
a lot of in cost this is a problem
familiar States to the United States is
spending a lot of money and pressure
defending South Korea and this is one of
the motivations of Trump to get American
forces out of there but the nuclear
demolition has to happen first okay when
you talk about that Eric well what
what's on the to-do list for Trump and
Kim in the next they've had eight months
they've made some progress we've got a
bit of a hiccup situation now what's
what's on the to-do list in for the
immediate future most likely the
preparation that they did not do for the
Hanoi summit they should start having
their underlings work out on the
preparation a little bit better next
time and come a little bit more prepared
for some concrete things that can be
done it was unprofessional that's that's
what people are saying and I think for
it to succeed I think North Korea is
gonna have to give up all of its nuclear
weapons or it's gonna have to make some
big steps
hurry up its nuclear weapons this is the
big call now
it's more about who is doing what first
so North Korea is looking at the u.s.
and they want all the sanctions to
believed and the u.s. is looking at
North Korea and they want a completely
nuclearization so who is gonna take the
first step I think Trump is taking the
first step Trump has treated Kim like
equal as a world leader something he
never had before so I think Trump his
strategy is to treat him like a world
leader that's that's trumps took the
first step nuke North Korea has to
deliver house to get rid of his nuclear
weapons from a very simplistic point of
view to look at this Kim has stopped
nuclear testing for like launch is good
yeah so three months yeah you can also
said that he took the first step
obviously I mean definitely this is
Trump's rhetoric right in essence the
political Liberty premier cleric to deal
with a call
chairman Kim is like a friend's like but
it seems that North Korea also wanted to
see the action and realistic steps from
the united state government you know the
North Korea is always a very stable
policy for this normalization first
normalization indoors the peace building
processes on the Korean Peninsula
however South Korean nicely
whenever the region changed their policy
the North Korean policies always also
changed always changes - that's why
there are some problems in building
trust Trust trust for a relationship and
on that note I'm gonna have to break you
off we've got to the end of the program
thank you all three for being here on
quadriga today great stuff really
fascinating discussion Trump and Kim
what next that's been our topic this
week on quadriga thanks for joining us
bye-bye and choose
[Music]